permit zoo magazine just released a
bunch of new screenshots and captions
for Dark Souls 3 detailing about four
new locations five new characters and
revealing a ton about our character and
the state of the world that were going
to be exploring in April we're also
going to talk about the gameplay footage
that was shown at PSX because we never
really got into it and it showed a
couple of new enemy types and new boss
and a new weapon so watch on for that
screenshots first though an article by
Destructoid states as they begin the
game players will find themselves
revived in the untended graves as an
uncontained 'old appears to be the new
holo how a resident translator law
master no jar let us know that the word
unhindered appears to have been
translated from the literal Japanese he
no na hai or ash without fire or flame
the agreed-upon English term appears to
be unkind
though so I guess I'll be using that too
this is the first time in a Dark Souls
game that we don't appear to be undead
functionally speaking being unkind 'old
seems to be the same as being undead but
um as stated in previous videos we
appear to be hunting down the rising
Lords of cinder and other heirs of fire
like us because it seems like we're one
ourselves just like we see the giant
Lord of cinder in the trailer rising
from the grave we ourselves are said to
come into this world revived at the
cemetery of people with no relatives
so the uncontained
graves but in Japanese this translates
to something more akin to graves of the
kingless shortly after our resurrection
however it happened we fight against
Gunda the ashen judge who tests our
prowess before letting us proceed gunda
eventually erupts into one of the black
masses we fought in the network test
apparently this thing spent a long
period of time
resting in gündüz body waiting for the
unconverted ruin of the world straight
up this is saying that our tutorial
level is gonna have a boss at the end of
it which is actually another one of
those Souls tropes that I love the
Destructoid article says that after
succeeding in this trial we head into
file link shrine a screenshot exists of
this place with a swordsman who has
mastered the dual curved swords in the
foreground the filing shrine looks so
similar to the shrine of Dark Souls 1
though there is an absence of a giant
mountain around it which probably rules
it out from being the same place but
what seems to be the trend is that these
shrines are built upon the place where
the fire is linked we meet a couple of
characters here firstly the bonfire
keeper who exists to attend to the
player she has lost her light and wears
a crown which covers her eyes you'll
notice she's also the same figure that
appeared in the trailer before she's the
one that put on the crown that had the
dark signs swirling within it there is
also a man seated at Firelink shrine
named Hawkwood he is a renowned fugitive
of the firaon Undead company the firaon
undead company implies that there is a
powerful force of undead being used to
fight so for once
undead aren't being shepherded or locked
away they appear to be a dominant force
in the world for the first time that we
know of at least it does bear mentioning
though that we don't know whether these
undead are fighting willingly or not so
I guess that remains to be seen
unhindered and crestfallen
he has no ornamentation beyond his
undead company armor and great soul
awkward fills that token crestfallen
spot we apparently always need to have
in a Souls game another curious thing to
note is that he's described as
unconditional undead company the thing
we don't know is how do we become on
kinder
and can you be undead and done kindled
at the same time marking yourself as an
undead appears to be a thing now as well
one of the characters in the screenshots
is described thus the clergyman wears
blue clothing as proof he is an undead
bears a large lid on his back this lid
seems to hold down someone who in time
will be born from among the undead
moving on because I don't think we're
prepared to understand that yet this
still shot appears to have leaked along
with all of the new info maybe it's a
scene from an upcoming trailer or
something what we see are ironclad
knights standing around in graves
whether they're looking inside the
graves or rising from the graves is
unclear
regardless look at the sword that
they're wielding it's undoubtedly a
replica of artorias sword and in fact
these swords are viewable in another
screenshot behind hawkwood at filing
shrine Artorius was a legendary night of
Gwyn and apparently he had great
influence because his weapon has been
passed down throughout the ages it
appears in Dark Souls 2 for example in
Dark Souls 3 though it looks like
someone has started smithing replicas of
it and speaking of Gwyn we learn about
one of his successors here as well this
translates to small man who calls
himself the king of kindling it's worth
noting that Lord of cinder is actually
king of kindling in Japanese he calls
himself Courtland laureth and he sits on
one of the five thrones at Firelink
shrine proclaiming himself to be the
lord of cinder interesting to note that
there are five Thrones perhaps there's
been one for every Lord of cinder in the
past this king is the self-proclaimed
lord of cinder perhaps he doesn't truly
live up to that title in some way and
finally he calls himself lute Leth the
war we explore in the network test used
to actually be called the wall of Lord
left and even though it's now called the
wall of lothric it's likely the domain
of this
tiny King additionally a player hoists a
small ringed banner upon the high wall
of lothric the birthplace of the former
king of kindling and company is spread
out below as though in a heap there are
a lot of landmarks in this screenshot so
if you're interested to learn about all
the different areas we've seen so far
and how they correlate with one another
then I've linked a really cool post by
TEDx in the description this next
screenshot shows a Pyromancer fighting
misshapen maggot like things there is a
reference here about how he's using
primitive magic the same sort of word
that was used for pyromancers in Dark
Souls 1 these are the sages who studied
at the great archive these swordsmen are
candlesticks that light the guiding
fires and they're covered in wax so that
they are not imprisoned by the cursed
magic of the books all this talk of
curses and archives it makes me think of
seats 2 main from Dark Souls 1 and there
are references to more dragons this is
an old ruin on a peak above the clouds
those that walk the path of the dragon
are directed to this place but the path
that leads here has been long lost in a
world that has been endlessly struggling
with light and dark this path of grey
dragons might be a pretty valid path in
Dark Souls 3 and finally a screenshot of
a dirty beast that looks kind of like
Amelia crossed with the cleric beast so
from all of this from all of the
screenshots that we've seen we realized
that a lot of the tropes and settings
from previous games they're still going
to be in Dark Souls 3 we have fire
keepers we have a filing shrine and one
of the translations even mentions that
we are on our way to becoming the lord
of cinder which in essence probably
means linking the flame the world is
like a pendulum swinging between light
and
and the thing at the center is linking
the flame when the flame is linked it's
like that pendulum gets pushed in one
direction or another yet it always
returns to the center nothing ever
really changes in Dark Souls 3 though it
seems like this time we're approaching
things from the side of the un-- kindled
instead of the undead it feels like
everything has been flipped
instead of humanity there are embers
instead of playing as an undead lusting
after humanity which are fragments of
the Dark Soul we are uncondensed
of the flame and instead of Dark Lord's
like nashandra and fragments of the
abyss there are Lords of cinder and as a
fire and as one of these loads of cinder
we hunt the others down just like before
where we were a fragment of dark hunting
down other parts of the abyss so it's
like we're fighting on the other side of
the same coin if that makes sense and in
the last video on this topic we talked
about how fire and dark are flip sides
of that same coin brought together when
Gwyn linked the fire and committed the
first sin I postulated that
the first sin was Gwyn linking the flame
to humanity linking dark and light
together inseparably so we would never
move on from this age and it seems like
Dark Souls 3 is piling on more evidence
that this is the case the biggest
question is how are on kindled created
how do you ascend from undeath if that's
what we're doing do you truly leave it
behind this is something worth fighting
over in the comments section I guess my
best guess is that maybe we play as an
undead who linked the flame in a past
life and that we're on kindled now since
our character does have a lot in common
with the other past lords of cinder who
were rising that's my best guess but
we'll have to wait and see anyway let's
get on to discussing the gameplay that
was really
at PS X as we walk towards the archway
the first thing we notice should be the
giant Spears shutting out of the ground
they're a bit of a clue as to what's
about to happen two enemies walk towards
us the player looks around probably
wondering where the giant manta ray from
demon souls is and going back for a
second if we slow down the footage and
zoom in I think we can just see one of
those Spears being fired from this tower
these light enemies stagger when you
roll into them which is a nice touch
from blood-borne if we weren't wearing
plate armor I'd actually think this is
blood-borne
all in all it's a cool little gameplay
sequence because you have to fight while
thinking constantly about that threat
from above the difference is in Demon
Souls where this sort of situation
played out at least you could see what's
firing at you this ambush is pretty
nicely timed it plays upon your desire
to find shelter and punishes you for
sort of getting the hell out of there
the lighting and the darkness in this
room looks pretty nice
this next scene has us walk through this
sacred place and I call it a sacred
place because there are petals rising up
towards the sky which definitely kind of
helps with that sacred feel hollows pray
to a giant tree which is in keeping with
the theme that we've seen in the demo
where gray hollows prayed to trees and
where some of those trees even had
hollows growing into them and it turns
out this tree isn't too different
perhaps this is what one of those
hollows successfully grew into generally
I don't like bosses that have you
balancing the actual boss with a lot of
little mobs usually that feels a little
bit cheap like a cheap way to increase
the difficulty thankfully though this
boss like the spears earlier appears to
target the mobs as well as yourself also
notice the weapon that were willing
it's the murakumo one of my favorite
weapons in the series actually we get to
see its webinar in action it seems to be
this long flowing spinning attack
the fight ends with the floor collapsing
as this boss enters his second phase a
lot of blood-borne bosses also made use
of this boss phase mechanic and I think
that we're seeing most bosses in Dark
Souls 3 make use of it as well and
that's it guys
big shout out to law master Naja who
helped with the translation as well as
Alex Roe who provided these really
beautiful Dark Souls themed music tracks
from his new album darksign you really
should check it out listening to this
soundtrack is like listening to what an
upcoming Seoul's Games soundtrack is
going to be there's so so many beautiful
tracks on there and thanks for watching
guys we'll see you in February